c'est l'heure de notre second débat
évidemment des bas de société vous le
savez on cherche le plus souvent
possible à le décaler volontairement de
l'actualité du jour on a choisi ce soir
de vous parler des déserts médicaux
selon l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France il manque 6000 généralistes dans
nos campagnes démonstration en Mayenne
avec Jérémy Hansmann
Evron 7000 habitants à 35 km de Laval et
ici sur toutes les lèvres la même
réponse est-ce que vous avez un médecin
traitant
mon médecin est parti à la retraite fin
juin 3 généralistes partent à la
retraite sans être remplacés alors début
septembre quand un nouveau médecin
arrive sur la commune tout le monde se
précipite pour s'inscrire ça c'est la
file d'attente à 14h en fait ça
reflétait ce besoin criant des personnes
d'avoir un médecin traitant et de et
d'avoir la perspective de pouvoir se
faire soigner le docteur André installé
ici depuis 8 ans était au première loge
il a dû refuser des nouveaux passions on
peut tout simplement pas les accueillir
donc il y a beaucoup d'amertume beaucoup
de la colère un petit peu dans ce
cabinet médical il exerce avec quatre
autres médecins à temps partiel grâce à
un fonctionnement collectif l'endroit
attire de jeunes praticiens et va même
s'agrandir avec ses préfabriqués
on aura deux bureaux de consultation un
troisième bureau qui servira soit à
l'arrivée d'une orthophoniste soit une
extension à 3e bureau médical on va voir
un nouveau généraliste s'installera en
novembre mais c'est encore insuffisant à
Evron 1800 habitants resteront sans
médecin traitant une arrivée compense la
moitié d'un médecin à peu près qui part
en retraite on a besoin d'accueillir
encore environ 2 à 3 jeunes médecins je
pense aujourd'hui il manque plus de 200
médecins généralistes en Mayenne et à
quelques kilomètres de là
à Jublin dans le nord du département le
désert médical est encore plus marqué on
a une salle d'attente et aussi un petit
studio où il y a kitchenette et puis
salle de bain chambre un cabinet complet
mais son médecin pour exercer depuis le
départ à la retraite au printemps
dernier de la seule généraliste du
secteur aujourd'hui il faut faire à peu
près 25 à 35 km pour trouver un médecin
traitant quand on compte toujours en
trouver un pourtant les lunes baissent
pas les bras avec le maire de la commune
voisine ils ont envoyé ce courrier à 300
médecins parisiens c'est pas une une
bouteille lancée à la mer mais mais en
se disant que on touche 300 médecins au
hasard qui soit eux-mêmes soit leur
entourage soit des collègues soit des
amis souhaiteraient peut-être quitter
leur vie parisienne l'objectif vanter
les mérites de la Mayenne pour tenter de
les attirer on a le plein emploi on a
une richesse culturelle importante sur
notre territoire on s'est dit que si on
était encore plus démunis que les autres
régions c'est peut-être parce qu'on
n'est pas aussi connu que d'autres
régions si on n'agit pas aujourd'hui
pour faire venir un médecin sur notre
territoire c'est l'ensemble de nos de
nos populations qui va se retrouver sans
mettre sans traitement un appel rester
pour l'instant sans réponse dans cette
commune de 750 habitants si on peine à
trouver des généralistes à la campagne à
Laval ce sont les médecins spécialistes
qui commencent à manquer
on va se retrouver sans gynécologue
médicaux libéraux en Mayenne dans
quelques temps donc c'est vrai que c'est
très inquiétant on attend plus d'un an
pour un rendez-vous d'ophtalmo en
consultation publique à l'hôpital en
attendant 9 mois presque un an en
cardiologie non c'est très inquiétant et
pour cette infirmier en hôpital il faut
encourager les internes à venir se
former ici on sait que les internes
d'aujourd'hui c'est les médecins de
demain dans nos hôpitaux et dans nos
territoires donc il faut peut-être
réfléchir à décentraliser cette
formation hyper centrée sur les CHU dans
nos hôpitaux périphériques pour vraiment
montrer ce que c'est la médecine aussi
de tous les jours une situation
désormais urgente en Mayenne où l'on
estime que 30% des habitants se font
soigner en dehors du département
pour ce débat sur les déserts médicaux
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Olivier à fréniot bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes présidente de
l'intersyndical national des internes
Frédéric bizard bonsoir bienvenue à vous
économie spécialisé question de
protection sociale et de santé
professeur d'économie affili filière à
l'escpe Europe et puis auteur de ce
livre l'autonomie solidaire en santé la
seule réforme possible c'est aux
éditions michalonge accueille également
Frédéric valtour bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes député horizon de la Seine-et-Marne
et ancien président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France vous avez passé
le relais il y a il y a quelques jours
quinzaine de jours une quinzaine de
jours en étant duplex également et je
l'accueille avec Christophe Dietrich le
maire de Laigneville bonsoir à vous 5000
habitants environ La Neuville c'est ça
c'est ça oui bon et je vous donnerai la
parole dans un cours instant Laetitia
cruppa il t'arrive politique est resté à
mes côtés peut-être une carte pour
ouvrir ce débat elle nous permet en fait
de visualiser un peu ce que sont les les
désert médicaux alors on va les voir
apparaître les déserts médicaux elle est
pointilliste mais ils sont en rouge là
c'est un manque criant de médecin
généraliste les zones oranges sont
également en sérieux déficit les vertes
sont excellentaires intéressants et
sinon les les cases blanches on va dire
les zones ou les circonscriptions
blanches on peut dire que tout que tout
va bien 4 réalisé par l'Association des
maires de France les données dates de ce
mois d'août 2022 donc c'est très récent
mais Frédéric bizard quand on parle de
déserts médicaux c'est pas nouveau
est-ce que ça s'aggrave est-ce qu'on
peut déjà faire ce premier constat oui
ça ne peut que s'aggraver parce qu'on
est dans un cercle vicieux qui fait que
vous avez à peu près 50% des par exemple
des médecins généralistes qui ont plus
de 55 ans donc beaucoup pas partent en
retraite laisse derrière eux des
cabinets médicaux avec moins de
praticiens parce que les praticiens ne
trouvent pas suffisamment rapidement de
remplaçant et donc les les praticiens
souvent assez âgés proches de la
retraite finissent par craquer s'en vont
etc donc on est dans ce phénomène là
sachant que
on a augmenté le numérique clausus il y
a déjà une douzaine d'années ce qui fait
que on commence à avoir des promotions
qui sont plus importantes d'où la part
très importante de ce que comment est-ce
qu'on traite les internes je pense qu'on
va y venir tout à l'heure donc oui on
est dans ce cercle vicieux il faut
savoir que ce cercle vicieux il a
démarré dans les établissements pour
personnes âgées où il y a quasiment
moins d'un médecin par établissement
donc un énorme désert médical puis c'est
poursuivi à l'hôpital où on a eu on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 30% de taux de
vacances pas exactement le dernier
chiffre enfin on était à 30%
et puis avec un phénomène de
mercenarisation on y reviendra en ville
parce qu'on a beaucoup mercenarisé les
médecins à l'hôpital pour essayer de
combler donc là aussi on est dans un
cercle vicieux c'est à dire qu'il y a de
plus en plus de médecins installés qui
qui se transforme en mercenaire et je
crains ce qui sont en ville beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher
que vous avez on estime qu'il y a 7 à
8000 médecins prenons plus aujourd'hui
qui qui vont combler les
de vacants dans les autres hôpitaux en
étant payé extrêmement cher ça coûte à
peu près un milliard 400 millions de
plus à l'hôpital donc on va probablement
avoir ce phénomène là ça peut aller
jusqu'à quel prix pour une pour une
journée de travail pour un mercenaire je
reprends l'expression de très bizarre
plusieurs milliers d'euros oui c'est
plusieurs milliers d'euros ça peut être
deux trois mille euros pour une journée
c'est-à-dire quasiment la moitié d'une
salaire en une journée
exagérant un peu parce qu'après il y a
des charges etc mais globalement oui en
disant qu'en une semaine on gagne
beaucoup plus qu'en un mois de praticien
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est un cancer
pour l'hôpital c'est c'est il y a
effectivement
ça s'est développé du fait le plein de
phénomènes il y a une souplesse comme ça
de de fonctionnement pour ceux qui le
font qui met à de l'autre côté ça
pénalise les hôpitaux ça sans doute
c'est pas non plus bon signe pour les
patients parce que les gens qui sont là
pour une semaine à moi c'est pas des
gens qui connaissent leur patient qui
connaissent les équipes avec qui
travaille qu'on peut les habitudes de
chaque hôpital et effectivement le
mercenaires il est justifié alors je
reviens et on est au cœur du sujet mais
sur cette désertification médicale avec
un chiffre que j'ai donné en titre tout
à l'heure six millions de Français n'ont
pas de médecin traitant donc 10% souffre
d'une affection de longue durée est-ce
que ça veut dire par exemple ce qu'on
appelle je crois une perte de chance
c'est à dire un risque les gens soient
tout simplement moins bien soigné
quand vous êtes quand vous êtes quand
vous avez une maladie chronique et
qu'effectivement vous ne pouvez pas
accéder régulièrement au médecin qui
suit votre état vous fait faire les
examens intermédiaires qui permettent
effectivement en cas d'aggravation la
situation et bien de vous orienter vers
tel ou telle spécialiste ou vers tel ou
telle et hôpital inévitablement vous
êtes tout seul dans votre coin à vous
détériorer et donc oui c'est un vrai
sujet de santé publique et c'est pour ça
que le ministreuse à la santé fait de
cet objectif qui est que chaque Français
est un médecin traitant à un des
objectifs de long terme de la politique
qui souhaite mener parce que c'est un
vrai souci de santé publique il y a deux
marqueurs qui doivent être suivis et
effectivement cette question à peu près
de 10 à 12% des Français qui n'ont plus
de médecin traitant dont certains
effectivement mériteraient largement de
ne pas être dans cette situation et puis
le deuxième c'est que la France certes
on vit longtemps mais on a une espérance
de vie en bonne santé qui est parmi les
plus faibles d'Europe c'est-à-dire on
vit longtemps mais on a une espérance de
vie en bonne santé aux alentours de 60
65 66 ans ce qui nous place loin
derrière des pays voisins comme l'Italie
l'Espagne l'Allemagne etc
on vit finalement assez peu en bonne
santé et assez longtemps donc ça veut
dire que les cases des 20 dernières
années de sa vie on a de fortes chances
d'être en mauvaise santé donc on est
consommateur de soins à un moment où le
système de santé est en train de se
péter la gueule alors les zones rurales
c'est évidemment dans ces zones-là que
c'est le plus compliqué pas seulement on
y viendra mais c'est quand même beaucoup
plus compliqué six fois plus difficile
de consulter un médecin en milieu rural
qu'en ville selon toujours cette étude
de des mers ruraux de France Olivia
fréniot est-ce que les jeunes médecins
ne veulent pas s'installer à la campagne
là je reviens au généraliste
en fait généralise tout pas je peux
étendre moi je représente des internes
de toutes les spécialités y compris la
médecine générale on a très envie
d'aller à la campagne ou d'aller dans
tous les territoires il y a pas de
freins particuliers à aller s'installer
dans une zone plus que dans une autre le
principal frein en fait c'est que avant
notre entente parce que globalement nos
études durent une dizaine d'années en
comptant les redoublements les années
césure etc on sait que les études de
médecine dure en général plus de 10 ans
à 30 ans quand on a passé ces dix années
et donc toute notre vingtaine à
construire toute notre vie dans la plus
grande agglomération de la région où il
y a le CHU où on est quasi exclusivement
en stage pendant toute notre formation
et qu'on a construit notre vie avec un
conjoint une conjointe avec des enfants
si pour cent des internes sont par an
donc ça fait quand même un certain
nombre on est plus de 30000 donc 6% ça
fait du monde
on ne parle plus de cette zone où on
s'est installé il faudrait anticiper
c'est il faudrait faudrait sortir de ce
tout CHU dans la la formation de
l'Internet
université centrée ou en tout cas
développer les universités rurales comme
ça peut se faire ailleurs pour inciter
déjà plus de jeunes de plus de milieux à
aller dans les études de médecine les
démocratiser davantage on reste dans des
études qui sont parmi les moins
démocratisés pour pour la population
générale et ça permettrait aussi de
faire découvrir les territoires dès le
plus jeune âge de ces étudiants et donc
leur donner envie de rester on sait que
dès la première année de l'internat des
la plupart des internes ont choisi le
lieu d'exercices où ils vont être en
tout cas pour leur première année parce
que ils y construisent leurs projets
professionnels et parce qu'ils y
rencontrent des équipes enfin quand ils
y rencontrent des équipes bienveillantes
donc il y a fort à parier que si dès
leur première année ils vont faire leur
stage dans des terrains des territoires
soudains en étant bien encadré bien sûr
et ben il se y projetteront ici
installant intéressant Christophe
Dietrich je me tourne vers peut-être
pour un retour d'expérience le désert
médical dans votre ville de Laigneville
ça ça a commencé comment c'est quoi le
point de départ le point de départ c'est
le départ des trois médecins en 2017 qui
avait une ville dont un couple et donc
ils sont partis en retraite et je me
suis retrouvé du jour au lendemain sans
aucun médecin voilà tout simplement pour
5000 habitants et on est à 60 km de
Paris il y a 60 km de Paris on est en
plein désert médical c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui
et quand vous entendez voilà
Olivia freignaux et évoqué la
possibilité de commencer sa formation
dans des dans des plus petites villes
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire je suis
assez dubitatif là-dessus faut pas
oublier quand même que ça fait ça fait
40 ans que ce sont les médecins qui font
les règles pour eux-mêmes et je me
rappelle quand on a fait les grandes
lois de santé des années 90 où on disait
qu'on avait droit dans le mur les
médecins nous disaient la main sur le
cœur vous inquiétez pas nous sommes déjà
en responsables ne nous mettez pas de
contraintes nous n'aurons pas de désert
médical en France et aujourd'hui non
seulement on a un désert médical en
France mais le désert médical
aujourd'hui s'accentue de plus en plus
et donc ça fait 40 ans qu'on a des
médecins qui font les règles pour
eux-mêmes et au final on ne prend
absolument pas en considération la
parole des élus locaux des habitants on
ne prend en compte que la parole des
médecins et ça c'est un peu regrettable
et aujourd'hui on a toujours ce même
problème moi je suis désolé on a à peu
près tout essayé on a donné de l'argent
pour que les médecins s'installent on
leur a payé des ordinateurs on a pris en
compte un certain nombre de choses je
crois qu'on arrive le moment où il
faudrait un peu de courage politique
pour mettre de la contrainte je ne
conçois pas qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
contingenter le nombre de pharmacies par
rapport au nombre d'habitat et on en a à
peu près partout et qu'on ne soit pas
aujourd'hui en capacité de faire la même
chose pour les médecins alors je sais
que ça va pas plaire ce que je dis je
sais que c'est pas du tout ce que les
médecins valentinent mais nous
aujourd'hui c'est la seule solution qui
permettra de pouvoir lisser sur le
territoire le nombre de médecins qu'on a
actuellement alors contraintes ou
incitation on est au cœur de notre débat
qu'est-ce que vous répondez alors il
fallait que bizarre il y a je voyais je
voyais ticket oui parce que on peut être
juste on peut être en désaccord avec les
solutions enfin faut être en accord avec
le diagnostic qui a réduit par deux le
numerus clausus pendant 15 ans qui a
fait qu'on a asséché en fait la capacité
de renouveler justement ce
vieillissement de la population ce sont
les médecins qui a proposé des mesures
extrêmement incitatives pour que les
médecins partent en pré-retraite dans
les années 90 sur les médecins non donc
sur les politiques donc je crois non
mais la responsabilité elle est
collective elle collective je rappelle
que la médecine est gérée par une
convention collective qui est négocié
entre l'assurance maladie et les
syndicats de médecins non mais ça les
médecins libéraux
oui je pense que d'abord il y a une
responsabilité collective c'est
important de le dire parce que il y a
des syndicats de médecins qui ont
soutenu aussi un certain nombre de ces
mesures là donc mais vous savez qu'un
médecin ça trois tribunaux au dessus de
cette tête quand j'entends ah oui mais
les médecins il faut arrête il faut
arrêter de les laisser faire ce qu'ils
veulent enfin c'est une méconnaissance
de la médecine qu'il faut juste un petit
peu rectifier encore une fois on peut
être d'accord sur un désaccord alors je
suis désolé allez on va donner la parole
et soviétique les médecins sont des
libéraux je l'entends bien faut pas
oublier quand même qu'ils sont payés
avec de l'argent public que c'est
l'argent de la cotisation des Français
et que à ce titre les Français ont droit
à un retour sur investissement sur la
santé travaillent pas assez par exemple
moi je peux vous parler du retour sur
investissement que subissent les
internes il y a aucun souci je peux vous
parler de ce que c'est que les études de
médecine les études
on va laisser on va laisser parler
après alors reprenez du début parce
qu'on sait pas compris tout le monde
parlait en même temps
que fait la société vis-à-vis des études
de médecine il n'y a aucun souci moi je
peux parler de l'investissement que font
les internes tous les jours pour faire
le choix d'aller soigner plus tard au
bout de 10 années d'études d'aller
soigner des gens d'aller en prendre soin
on a tous à coeur cette vocation là et
pour aujourd'hui ce que ça coûte c'est
des troubles psychologiques c'est 40 %
des internes qui sont en dépression
c'est 60 % de Burn Out c'est 70 %
d'anxiété pathologique c'est la
population qui se suicide le plus en
France donc il y a aucun souci on peut
on peut bien sûr parler de ce que les
internes doivent à la société on peut
aussi parler de ce que l'État le
gouvernement l'hôpital ou qui vous
voulez doit aux internes je pense en
tout cas que ce qui est sûr c'est que
les internes n'entendent pas et je le
dis avec avec grande conviction parce
que j'en représente 30000 n'entendent
plus payer le tribu des erreurs passées
parce que c'est ça qu'on nous demande de
faire de dire que nous on va aller
s'installer nous les jeunes parce qu'il
y a 30 ou 40 ans des gens peu importe
qu'ils sont ont décidé de mieux se
partager à part du gâteau c'est NON à la
contrainte et au congés au
contingentement un hameau Christophe
Dietrich et je vais vers Frédéric ils
veulent tout juste après rappel je suis
désolé moi aussi j'ai bouffé des
cailloux jusqu'à l'âge de 28 ans et je
considère pas pour autant que l'État ne
doivent quelque chose ni personne vous
comprenez donc ce discours
culpabilisateur il faut un peu en sortir
si on veut pouvoir avancer après sur le
fait que vous n'ayez pas envie de payer
les éléments de vos prédécesseurs mais
je l'entends très bien malheureusement
aujourd'hui la situation escalier c'est
un fait et donc il faut y faire face
alors il faut trouver des solutions
juste les cailloux que vous avez mangé
on les a tous mangés quand on était
quand on était sauf que faut savoir que
aucun hôpital ne tourne sans les
internes et si vous saviez le salaire
des internes pendant à peu près 4 ans
quand ils ont entre 25 et 29 ans je
pense que là aussi vous voyez il faut
mettre les faits ça vous vous pouvez pas
dire ça vous pouvez pas dire que les
internes doivent quelque chose à l'état
parce que c'est c'est juste sur ce que
vous dites nous on a fait des études qui
prouvent que l'État économiste 360 000
euros par interne
j'ai pardon mais j'ai pas compris dans
les propos de Monsieur le Maire qui
l'opposait les internes à l'intérêt
général ou aux soins je pense que il
pointait simplement le fait
pour les pharmaciens c'est une vérité
c'est qu'au fil du temps tu as la
médecine c'est exonéré d'un certain
nombre de contraintes qu'on le veuille
ou non parlons de l'histoire de
l'installation parlant de l'histoire des
gardes et de ses décisions
quelques années avant que émerge la
problématique des déserts médicaux qui
en 2003 décide qu'effectivement les
médecins libéraux ont accès exonéré de
de ce qu'on appelait tour de garde avant
donc les jeunes y sont pour rien c'était
il y a une vingtaine d'années mais enfin
la réalité elle est là on parle pas du
siècle dernier c'était il y a 20 ans et
bien c'est vrai que ce sont les jeux
d'un certain nombre de contraintes et
ont du mal aujourd'hui par la jeune
génération et les syndicats à comprendre
que
le temps a changé que les Français
attendent autre chose
des médecins en général et
qu'effectivement
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui pour eux de
faire un chemin arrière à celui qui a
été fait pendant longtemps donc ils se
sont pardon mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une médecine à
deux vitesses il y a les soutiers il y a
ceux qui sont effectivement les internes
qui sont un peu parlons l'expression
elle est vraiment pas belle mais ceux
qui viennent un peu remplir les pas les
trous mais en tout cas ceux qui viennent
boucher les justement voilà la variable
justement mais c'est vrai il faut dire
les choses de manière crue et donc c'est
un peu la variable d'ajustement il y a
ceux qui ont les salaires qu'ils ont et
notamment à l'hôpital où on peut pas
dire que les salaires des médecins
gèrent sont très élevés et puis et puis
et puis il y en a d'autres on le sait il
faut le dire il y a une médecine à deux
vitesses aujourd'hui et puis il y a un
monde libéral qui s'est décroché de ce
que c'est ce qu'est aujourd'hui
l'intérêt général
que vous travaillez à l'hôpital ou une
fois dans une clinique vous gagnez du
simple au quintuple ou quadruple dans
certaines spécialités comme la
radiologie parfois de l'hôpital il est
d'un côté de la rue et la clinique elle
est de l'autre côté de la rue d'un côté
de la rue vous avez les week-ends
tous les jours et de l'autre vous avez
des agendas que vous que vous des
programmes que vous organisez etc ce que
je veux dire je ne jette pas la pierre
sur cela
pas de professeur mais c'est université
donc il y a des gens qui préfèrent je
reprends la main parce que on va on va
ça va continuer d'alimenter notre débat
on va on va se concentrer sur une mesure
qui a été annoncée par le ministre de la
Santé je propose à terme traduit qui
doit être juste derrière le rideau en
coulisses de nous de nous rejoindre donc
on est au cœur de cette question
contrainte ou incitation donc cette idée
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
c'est donc d'ajouter pardon une
quatrième année d'internat pour les
étudiants en médecine générale voilà une
mesure de dernière minute rajoutez au
projet de budget de la Sécurité sociale
pour l'année prochaine il mesure qui
propose donc d'allonger d'un an
l'internat des médecins généralistes
avec un stage effectué en médecine de
ville en priorité dans les zones sous
tension ce n'était pas une surprise
puisqu'emmanuel Macron l'avait annoncé
dès la présentation de son programme
comme candidat à sa réélection écoutée
la réforme qui a été portée par le
ministre de la Santé dans la loi prévoit
cette quatrième année qui était une
demande des étudiants donc là dessus ce
que je dis c'est qu'on doit l'utiliser
davantage pour permettre d'inciter à des
semestres dans les déserts médicaux je
ne suis pas pour qu'elle soit
systématiquement conduite dans ces
déserts médicaux mais qui est une
politique d'incitation qui peut passer
par une meilleure rémunération d'une
part et un meilleur accompagnement en
termes de logement entre autres
sur ces sujets voilà donc une mesure qui
suscite déjà la levée de boucliers des
syndicats d'étudiants en médecine qui
écrit au passage en force au manque de
concertation et puis il y a aussi
l'opposition à l'opposition qui s'oppose
aussi à bien entendu même si les
arguments de la droite sont plus de
forme que de fond parce que la droite
avait cette mesure dans ces cartons au
mois de janvier dernier le patron des
sénateurs les républicains Bruno
retaillod également candidat à la
présidente du parti a déposé une
proposition de loi son objectif je cite
le communiqué un de l'époque créer une
quatrième année d'internat pour les
médecins généralistes cette année de
professionnalisation et de consolidation
amènera les internes de cette nouvelle
4ème année à exercer en priorité dans
les zones sous dotées ça ressemble donc
mot pour mot à ce que propose le
gouvernement le résultat c'est que Bruno
Retailleau il est pas content du tout
regardé donc ce qu'il a tweeté le 27
septembre dernier le gouvernement
intègre au PLFSS le budget de la
Sécurité sociale un amendement pour
créer une quatrième année de médecine
alors qu'un texte sur ce et déjà inscrit
à l'ordre du jour du Sénat cette méthode
n'est ni respectueuse du Parlement ni
efficace le Conseil constitutionnel
risque d'annuler ce cavalier au budget
de la Sécurité sociale l'argument c'est
donc de dire que cette mesure elle n'a
rien de budgétaire donc elle n'a rien à
faire dans le budget de la Sécu et les
sénateurs ont aussi bien sûr le
sentiment que le gouvernement essaye de
leur couper l'herbe sous le pied est-ce
que le gouvernement va voter le texte
des LR et vice-versa c'est toute la
question est-ce que le gouvernement peut
refuser de voter la proposition de loi
de Bruno retaillod qui sera donc
débattue le 18 octobre alors que
l'exécutif propose exactement la même
chose dans un texte qui examinait
quasiment en même temps à l'Assemblée et
si le gouvernement s'y refuse est-ce que
les LR peuvent continuer à s'opposer sur
de pures questions de forme alors qu'ils
veulent eux aussi cette quatrième année
qui se déroule prioritairement dans les
zones sous tension écoutez c'est pas la
première fois que ce cas de figure se
présente au Parlement c'est fréquent
qu'un exécutif refuse une la position
parlementaire pour sortir parfois un
mois plus tard un projet de loi
équivalent et cela pour son attribut la
paternité c'est classique mais entre ce
qui se passe sur les retraites ou les
décans défendent tout de même la
retraite à 65 ans et cet exemple si on a
sérieusement l'impression que les deux
camps passent leur temps à se tirer
labour c'est vous me permettez
l'expression mais aussi parce qu'il
défendent bien souvent c'est en si les
mêmes mesures merci Tam alors on va pas
refaire l'analyse politique on pourrait
en rire de de tout ça sauf que c'est la
question des déserts médicaux il y en a
commencé en disant que il y avait des
pertes de chances pour certains patients
donc c'est quand même très très
important cette quatrième année
d'internat elle n'est pas obligatoire
elle sera incitative alors je vous vois
je vous vois ticket parce que vous
n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord vous
vous y opposez pourquoi la quatrième
année en elle-même sera obligatoire ce
sera les lieux de stage qui se
uniquement incitatif
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que la quatrième année de médecine doit
être si elle est faite une année qu'on
construit à viser pédagogique or
l'inclure de la sorte dans le PLFSS dans
un contexte où on a des des PPL
coercitives qui qui sortent de tous les
partis et au vu des débats qu'il y a
actuellement la crainte et d'ailleurs
c'est présenté comme une solution à
moyen terme d'accès aux soins or on le
disait en préambule de cette émission
les les internes sont des gens qui vont
rester pendant 6 mois ou un an dans le
territoire et les populations ont besoin
de gens qui s'investissent dans ces
territoires notamment de médecins qui
investissent envie d'y rester ensuite
alors oblige quelqu'un qu'on oblige
quelqu'un à aller quelque part il
n'irait jamais il va partir ça je vous
en fais la certitude et je peux aussi
dire d'ailleurs parce qu'on parlait tout
à l'heure du fait que ils sont payés par
l'agent des contribuables aucun problème
si on leur dit mais vu que vous êtes
payés par la sécu vous devez tant
d'années si on les oblige à le faire ils
vont se décomventionner et on va
aggraver des inégalités qui existent
déjà moi je pense que vraiment
l'obligation ça va pas marcher parce
qu'il y a la vérité les chiffres que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure on peut croire
que c'est pas bien de culpabiliser avec
ça le fait est que les internes ne
veulent pas d'une quatrième année dans
les conditions qu'il vivent actuellement
à l'hôpital et on peut l'entendre parce
qu'en fait il meurt dans ces conditions
qu'ils ne veulent pas qu'on leur impose
leur exercice d'après alors que pendant
10 ans il se seront donnés pour pouvoir
devenir médecin et qu'ils ne veulent pas
qu'en plus cette quatrième année qui est
censée être quelque chose pour mieux les
former pour mieux les aider à prendre en
charge leur patients de demain soit en
fait une mesure à bas coût parce que
c'est ça la vérité pour le gouvernement
pour répondre à une situation urgente
qui est urgente depuis 30 ans
il y a deux aspects il y a effectivement
cette quatrième année qu'on rajoute dans
le cursus de général qui est demandé par
les étudiants en médecine générale non
je représente 45%, je peux vous dire que
ce n'est pas demandé par les étudiants
en médecine générale et si mes collègues
de l'isnard étaient là ils vous dirait
qu'historiquement il n'était pas en
faveur non plus de cette quatrième année
c'est un mensonge de la campagne
présidentielle c'est un mensonge de
monsieur le ministre de la Santé
monsieur Braun qui l'a encore dit pas
plus tard que ce week-end a une
convention médicale c'est faux ce n'est
pas une demande des étudiants en
revanche si on doit supporter cette
quatrième année on veut être force de
proposition on veut construire cette
maquette ça se passe pas encore contre
nous pourquoi je pense que cette idée
vous la soutenez pourquoi non mais enfin
ce qui était demandé pardon par les
étudiants c'était de caler le faire de
faire en sorte de reconnaître que la
médecine générale était une spécialité
ce qui a été fait il y a quelques années
et de caler donc les maquettes de de
d'apprentissage ou d'études de toutes
spécialité pour la médecine générale
c'est à dire de passer de 3 à 4 ans
d'internat voilà c'est tout donc c'était
pas alors ensuite c'est une fois qu'on a
gagné d'inciter aller dans les zones
c'est là aussi où je voudrais revenir
parce que
on dit on entend du président de la
République et du ministre le mot
d'incitation et vous-même vous reprenez
en disant c'est une on nous fait
l'obligation 2 d'abord je voudrais dire
que on va pas dire à tel étudiant tu vas
aller dans ce canton là ou dans ce
quartier de l'Est parisien qui est sous
doté il y a les deux tiers du territoire
qui sont quasiment sous dotés et quand
je dis de dire je pense que c'est des
chiffres qui datent un peu je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus on doit être plus
proche des trois quarts donc je veux
dire la carte est vaste et je veux dire
la carte est vaste pour choisir
l'endroit où on va s'installer donc il y
a pas on va pas diriger les uns les
autres vers des territoires ou de vrais
pas les ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est incitatif ça bien
été dit et présent dans la République a
dit dans le projet loi gerge élu le
texte qui proposait par le gouvernement
c'est sur la base de l'incitation donc
là aussi c'est pareil qui ne veut pas y
aller n'y va pas mais qui veut y aller
pourra sans doute un accompagnement qui
sera différent de celui qui ne veut pas
y aller mais quelque part enfin il faut
bien comprendre et je reprends les les
propos de de Monsieur le Maire de tout à
l'heure enfin c'est difficile à
comprendre aussi pour les Français de de
de dire que on n'est pas capable en
France de dire par exemple à au 12e
spécialiste qui va s'installer dans une
belle ville attractive de la Côte d'Azur
parce que il a des conditions de vie
agréables écoutez est-ce que c'est à la
solidarité nationale de payer l'exercice
du xm je sais pas quoi moi cardiologue
ou
ou ophtalmo qui va s'installer alors
qu'il y en a peut-être pas besoin qu'on
a déjà suffisamment et qu'effectivement
les besoins ils sont partout ailleurs et
le problème c'est que les médecins ne
font semblant de ne pas comprendre que
il l'a il y a un sujet et qu'il faut te
ferait mieux faire des propositions
parce que il y a un fossé qui est en
train de se creuser entre les médecins
et les Français qui ne comprennent plus
pourquoi on en arrive là et pourquoi sur
d'accord il y a ce refus systématique de
toute solution ce rêve de l'État
Léviathan qui descendent on a vu ce que
ça a donné avec l'hôpital premier point
c'est une drôle de façon de gouverner
quand même d'agir de la sorte
journaliste là très bien dit d'abord
cette mesure n'a rien à faire dans le
périphéss qui est une qui est une loi
strictement réservée à ce que ça peut
être une bonne mesure
c'est une drôle de façon de gouverner de
ne pas avancer qu'il y ait eu une
concertation la plus poussée possible
avec ceux qui sont concernés parce que
vous annoncez pendant une campagne
présidentielle sur un principe très
vague que vous avez concerté attention
attention quand il y a des débuts de
grève avec la jeunesse je dis juste que
attention où ça peut on sait jamais où
ça peut aller et je d'ailleurs Paris que
ça va avoir un effet contagion étant
donné la tension qu'il y a dans le
système de santé il y a un risque de
contagion très important sans interne
les hôpitaux ne tournent pas il n'y a
pas simplement des problèmes dans les
soins primaires il y aura des problèmes
ailleurs et votre question est
exactement celle qu'il faut poser moi si
je pensais sincèrement que cette mesure
était efficace j'en serait le premier
défenseur même si la coercition n'a
jamais été véritablement ma tasse de thé
non non mais on sait bien où ça va non
parce que vous savez vous savez bien que
c'est toujours on démarre ça fait 15 ans
d'être coercitif et 15 ans qu'il ne faut
rien faire c'est de dire si vous n'allez
pas dans ce territoire là votre vie va
être une misère bon donc c'est une façon
de le faire tout autant donc on a vu
encore une fois qu'est-ce qui va se
passer qu'est-ce qui va se passer parce
que ceux qui ont le pouvoir pour dans la
médecine c'est ni les mers ni l'État ni
les fédérations c'est ce qu'on le
diplôme d'accord donc c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les hôpitaux on a vu quand on
a été excessivement directive ou pas
assez attractif dans les hôpitaux les
médecins soient sont partis soit ce sont
mes scénarisés donc soyez sûr d'une
chose c'est qu'il va se passer
exactement la même chose dans les
territoires c'est-à-dire que les
médecins les internes et quel est on va
le rapport on va leur proposer
la proposition c'est la reconstruction
totale du système c'est-à-dire que il
faut aller à un service public on est
tous d'accord qu'il faut un service
public aussi en ville donc il faut
construire le service public qui
n'existe qu'à l'hôpital dans les textes
dans l'organisation donc il faut
construire un service public territorial
de santé avec les acteurs il faut gérer
à partir des territoires donc il faut
construire des territoires de santé
unique arrêtez avec ces ght c'est CPTs
c'est territoire de santé ça n'a ça n'a
aucun sens donc il faut reconstruire
mais vous allez me dire oui ça peut
prendre du temps ça prend pas des années
mais ça peut prendre du temps mais une
fois que vous avez donné vous montrer la
lumière au bout du tunnel parce que
c'est un tunnel aujourd'hui pour en
particulier pour les jeunes là vous
pouvez commencer à vous mettre autour de
la table et à vous dire en attendant il
faut qu'on règle les problèmes de court
terme bon les règles Pâques avec les
jeunes on les règle aussi avec ceux qui
ont envie de parler juste j'ai
l'impression que la communication du
ministère de la Santé a très mal
fonctionné je ne sais pas si vous savez
que le ministre de la Santé a lancé le
volet la santé du Conseil national de la
refondation lundi au Mans c'est à dire
que une grande concertation avec les
citoyens les experts médicaux les
experts
donc ce ne seront pas des mesures
coïncides
on va se poser la question puisque vous
avez pris la parole je vous la je vous
la laisse Laetitia la question de la
marge de manœuvre on va dire d'un d'un
ministre de la Santé qui est lui-même
médecin oui c'est un peu difficile de
savoir est-ce qu'on a une marge de
manœuvre liberté comme ça pour imposer
quelque chose assez pair quand on est
soi-même du sérail alors c'était pas le
premier choix de Emmanuel Macron
François brode je vous rappelle qu'il y
avait quand même madame bourguignon
Brigitte de son prénom qui avait été
choisi mais elle a perdu aux élections
législatives donc bon ben en cas de
crise en général c'est vrai qu'on
appelle le pompier du sérail on a eu
Olivier Véran médecin pendant le covid
là on a François Brown qui est aussi
médecin fils de médecin généraliste ex
urgentiste et syndicaliste il a été
notamment le conseiller santé d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est lui qui a préparé la
deuxième campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
deuxième campagne présidentielle et donc
on est au cœur de du débat que l'on a
depuis tout à l'heure incitation ou
coercition c'est plus difficile pour un
médecin d'imposer la coercition c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de dire oui j'ai
aimé cette hypothèse quand on est à
l'intérieur d'un système mais qu'on
appartient à une corporation c'est plus
difficile et qu'on a peut-être même la
casquette de l'obéisse hein Thomas il
était syndicaliste donc c'est peut-être
plus difficile oui d'imposer quelque
chose à ses pairs et d'ailleurs pendant
toute la campagne présidentielle ça a
été très clair il n'y aura pas de
coercition Emmanuel Macron la répéter
par exemple il y a une mesure que
François borne là a posé justement au
Mans lundi parce qu'il n'y a pas que
cette quatrième année il y a aussi
peut-être une façon d'inciter les jeunes
issus de ces zones sinistrées qui
veulent être médecin
peut aussi installer quand on est issu
d'un territoire peut-être que soi-même
on a vécu la difficulté d'accéder à des
médecins et qu'on a envie de résoudre le
problème une fois qu'on est médecin
François home qui affirme aussi qu'à
chaque fois que le gouvernement a essayé
de contraindre les médecins il s'est
confronté à l'univers de bouclier ça
c'est vrai et c'est le mieux que
personne puisse encore une fois je vous
le répète il était président du syndicat
SAMU urgence de France il y a une autre
donnée Thomas tout de même on voit pas
tout mettre sur les épaules du ministre
de la santé il y a quand même ce corps
médical qui est majoritairement Macron
compatible donc c'est vrai que imposer
quelque chose et de faire une politique
de façon coercitive c'est certainement
difficile pour un président qui préfère
d'horloter son électorat Christophe
Dietrich à qui faudrait confier une
grande réforme de la santé sinon au
médecin
un élu qui a du courage politique tout
simplement aujourd'hui on est un petit
peu le sentiment et j'entends les
discours là qui me semblent un petit peu
corporatiste on a sentiment aujourd'hui
on a un ministre où il avait dit qui
était syndicaliste et qui tient
parfaitement un discours presque
syndicaliste médical aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que le ministère de la
Santé les agences régionales de santé
l'ordre des médecins les syndicats de
médecins sont bras dessus bras dessous
n'ont pas pour faire valoir les intérêts
de la population mais plutôt pour faire
valoir des intérêts corporatistes du
terrain nous c'est exactement le ce qui
ressort du discours que l'on entend de
de tous ces gens là et on entend
toujours le même discours aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on sorte un peu des discours il
faut qu'on sorte un petit peu du
corporatisme et qu'on se penche vraiment
sur sur les difficultés qu'on a quand
vous avez des organismes comme les
agences régionales de santé qui ont un
pouvoir absolu sur lesquels les préfets
n'ont absolument aucune donne c'est une
anomalie quand les ARS pour ne pas vous
mettre dans un secteur médical sensible
pour pas dire que vous êtes en situation
médicale sensible vous raccroche à le
médecin de Chantilly qui sont à 25 km
d'ici alors que entre les deux il y a le
bassin créois c'est une aberration
totale et on vient vous dire mais non
monsieur vous avez des médecins en plus
vous avez des hôpitaux bientôt on va
nous compter les marabouts et le
rebouteux pour nous dire qu'il y a pas
de désert médical en France donc il y a
un moment il a peut-être falloir qu'on
mette à la tête d'un ministère un
personnage politique avec le courage
politique qui va bien la zone zone
sensible ce qui permet d'ouvrir d'ouvrir
des financements je voudrais il nous
reste aller 7 7 8 minutes je voudrais
qu'on soit un peu dans la proposition
parce que voilà on a fait le constat on
a bien compris que il y avait pas de
solution idéale ou de solution simple
qu'est-ce que vous vous proposez pour
pour améliorer je pense pas très court
terme mais au moins un moyen terme cette
question est désert médicaux
effectivement à court terme c'est
compliqué quand ça fait autant d'années
que on a arrêté d'investir dans dans un
système de santé les solutions à long
terme on les a déjà évoquées à court
terme et à moyen terme je pense que les
principales leviers qu'il faut qu'on
développe en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
pense nous l’inter syndical c'est de
libérer du temps médical de permettre
aux médecins et de proposer des projets
professionnels aux jeunes médecins qui
correspondent à ce qu'ils veulent c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a de plus en
plus de médecins qui ne veulent pas
s'installer à temps plein dans un
cabinet dans un seul territoire donné
aujourd'hui ce que les jeunes veulent ce
sont des exercices mixtes dès le début
de leur carrière qui ça veut dire
hôpital et et cabinet ville
ça veut dire pouvoir
au cours d'une même semaine entre
différents lieux ou au cours d'un
mémoire enfin je veux dire tous les
formations envisageables entre
différents lieux entre différents modes
d'exercices pour avoir pour pouvoir
soigner différentes populations et pour
pouvoir répondre à ce qu'ils ont envie
aussi parce qu'ils ont moins envie
d'être libéraux et plus envie d'être
salarié qu'avant je aussi dans un monde
où les médecins de demain sont en fait
des médecins femmes des des on a eu à
60% des internes qui sont en fait des
femmes qui ont recherche une certaine
sécurité notamment dans les désirs de
parentalité parce que aujourd'hui être
libéral et vouloir avoir une maternité
ça reste quelque chose de compliqué et
aussi parce qu'on fait face à de plus en
plus de violence quand on s'installe
seul en ville et dans des zones un peu
reculées et notamment dans les créer des
de poids parce que vous travaillez en
groupe finalement pendant votre
scolarité enfin toute votre formation
est restée en groupe quoi d'une certaine
façon oui bah finalement vu que pense au
CHU à travailler en équipe comment
est-ce qu'on peut avoir envie de
travailler tout seul ok j'entends ça
alors soyez bizarre je sais que vous
êtes pour une grande réforme mais si il
y a si si on essaye de trouver une
solution peut-être le la décision la
plus urgente qu'il faudrait prendre pour
contrer ces déserts il y a pas de
solution ça n'existe pas ça fait depuis
3 ans vous avez cité autonomie solidaire
en acné on a réfléchi 150 personnes de
toutes spécialité de toute tendance
politique bon on est arrivé sur un
modèle qu'on a présenté dans dans 8
jours donc c'est compliqué d'abord il y
a pas de solution mais j'irai dans le
sens du maire autant sa précédente
intervention ou c'est totalement
désaccord autant je suis à 100% d'accord
avec son non non sur la gouvernance
monsieur le maire dit à très juste titre
il faut repolitiser la santé la santé
est gérée de façon purement comptable et
technique d'accord vous n'avez aucune
orientation politique sur le système de
données donc la santé c'est pas
simplement d'abord du soin c'est
la bonne santé est beaucoup plus
importante encore que que le soin c'est
c'est la bonne santé par excès le soin
par défaut donc vous voyez qu'il faut
réorganiser ça d'ailleurs dans ce
nouveau modèle où les mers les
collectivités territoriales auront un
rôle donc repolitisé la santé comment on
peut le faire mais par exemple on peut
le faire en proposant une loi
d'orientation et de programmation
sanitaire à cinq ans c'est à dire a
demandé à ce que l'État définit une
vraie stratégie de long terme qui soit
débattue au Parlement et qui soit aussi
débattus pendant les campagnes
présidentielles et ensuite il faut lui
donner il faut une réforme
institutionnelle majeure puisque on a
aujourd'hui des ARS qui sont purement
administratives très peu de compétences
en santé publique alors que ça doit être
le bras armé de l'État dans les régions
en santé publique ensuite tout ce qui
concerne la conduite et la tutelle des
professionnels de santé nous nous
pensons d'abord qu'il faut quelque chose
d'unitaire d'unifier et il faut arrêter
d'avoir l'hôpital avec l'État le la
ville avec l'assurance maladie et puis
les établissements pour personnes âgées
avec la cns-5 et nationale de santé
autonomie donc il faut unifier ça
unifier ça sous un même toit propose que
ça soit l'assurance maladie qui serait
bien appelée assurance santé et il faut
partir encore une fois de la gestion à
partir de territoires par 450
territoires de santé 150 000 habitants
et là vous confiez ces territoires à un
pool de représentant des professeurs de
santé des représentants des patients les
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et vous leur confiez sous
forme de délégation de service public
est au cœur du modèle véritablement la
gestion de ces territoires alors je dis
pas que ça va être ça va tout régler
mais on sait bien que quand d'abord on
responsabilise les acteurs c'est pas la
coercition on les responsabilise
d'accord et on leur demande de régler
les problèmes de santé publique et les
problèmes d'accès aux soins on sait bien
quand il y a des gens réfléchissent sur
un territoire qui connaissent par cœur
les solutions viennent beaucoup plus
facilement que si c'est décidé on
centrale alors cette idée de
territorialiser d'une certaine façon
on est plusieurs à défendre et je
partage ce point de vue on est plusieurs
à défendre l'idée de donner du chant
aussi de donner de la prévision et c'est
on sait pas concerté c'est un amendement
on peut les faire c'est que j'ai déposé
cet après-midi la création d'une loi de
programmation quinquennale sur 5 ans
pour la santé il y en a bien pour
l'effort permet pour la défense il y en
a bien des lois de programmation pour la
sécurité intérieure la santé est une un
grand pan de politique publique et on
voit l'attachement des Français à ce
sujet là et donc de proposer
effectivement qu'on est une loi de
programmation quinquennale qui donne des
repères sur 5 ans sur comment vont
évoluer et les financements et par
rapport à des priorités exprimées et
puis oui effectivement la gouvernance et
les confuses aujourd'hui qui qui
comprend qui fait quoi dans le système
de santé entre des des gens qui ont pas
les mêmes statuts compas les mêmes
obligations qui ont pas les mêmes
charges qui sont gérés dans des
effectivement dans des dans des
fonctionnements très différents donc
repartir du terrain donné confiance aux
professionnels de santé reconnaître
aussi que il y a les médecins mais il y
a aussi les paramédicaux donner plus de
responsabilités aux infirmiers aux
infirmières aux pharmaciens ça ça
pourrait alors là je suis très court
termiste régler une partie une petite
partie de la question le bras là aussi
de certains syndicats qui qui se sont
pas les jeunes mais qui sont un peu
cramponnés sur ces oui vous vous êtes en
faveur mais pas tous Voilà parce que
c'est vrai que
et en duplex c'était vraiment
passionnant je vais citer de nouveau
votre livre Fédéric bizard l'autonomie
solidaire en santé la seule réforme
possible livre publié aux éditions
Michalon voilà je vous dis à lundi et
puis je vous donne rendez-vous en nom
Doriane morcenis demain matin 8h elle
reçoit au berger la priant du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée